but here are the new rules if you would
like a big publicly held corporation to
pay its taxes then you're a child rapist
obviously you're a racist you're like
putin which means you're a fascist but
you know what else you are
according to joy reid
you're a communist ron desantis is quote
taking us back to the soviet union
you're a communist
if you want the company to pay its taxes
now joyride went to harvard so we're not
going to disagree with her but we did
feel a moral obligation to check that
fact because it's a heavy claim so
joining us tonight to confirm or deny
these charges is comrade ron desantis
who is also the governor of florida
governor thanks so much for coming on
tonight so i can't tell whether you're
a racist communist fascist for wanting a
big publicly held corporation to pay its
taxes how would you describe yourself
well it's interesting tucker not only
pay taxes i mean this company had a deal
unlike any company or any individual in
all of the state of florida and probably
anywhere in the united states they were
self-governing they had extraordinary
powers they could build nuclear power
plants they didn't have to go through
permitting processes obviously a lot of
tax benefits and so that's just
inappropriate and it's certainly
inappropriate when you look as you i
think did a great job pointing out
they pledged themselves to mobilize
their considerable corporate resources
out of the coffers of this burbank
california-based corporation to overturn
the rights of parents in the state of
florida to effectively commandeer our
democratic process and so that obviously
is something that that we very much
objected to and then you also have those
videos that you showed where you have
all these higher-ups in disney talking
about how it was their intent to inject
sexuality in the programming that goes
to young kids i got a five-year-old a
four-year-old and a two-year-old at home
tucker i want them to be able to watch
cartoons without having this stuff jam
down their throats and so
it was appropriate to have done this
originally
three years ago whatever but it's
certainly appropriate to make them live
under the same laws as everybody else in
the state of florida well yes and it's a
little weird coming from people who
devote their programming um to defending
quote democracy so you've been elected
by the voters of florida you're standing
for election very soon in november and
we'll see how you do
but you're a product of democracy bob
chapic and bob iger were elected by
nobody so why wouldn't democracy
defenders be on the side of the
legislative process over corporate fiat
because i think what the left has come
to is all they want to see is power
exercised in advance of their leftist
agenda so yes they used to be hostile to
big corporations because i think they
perceive those corporations as being a
political and that they wouldn't support
their agenda now they figured out that
they can try to subcontract out their
leftism to some of these big
corporations and some of the executives
will cave to the woke mob and then
they'll basically do the less dirty work
tucker they're not going to win
elections in florida if they're actually
running on injecting transgender
ideology into second grade classrooms
and they know that so their hope was
getting disney involved in that would
somehow get me to back down from signing
the bill well uh that was a bad uh
judgment in their part because of course
we weren't going to back down an inch
it's a little weird because there are a
bunch of republican governors in the
country you're actually a republican
governor that sits over one of the most
evenly divided states it's a republican
state but just barely overwhelmingly
republican states in the west like utah
their governors have done nothing like
this they haven't fought back at all why
is that do you think
you know i don't know tucker i mean i
think the way i view it is is you have
the media class you have kind of the
twitter class you have some of these
people and that's a distorted view of
reality and you actually need to talk to
people who aren't always on those
outlets and listen to what they have to
say and i can tell you they do not want
this woke garbage in our society they
don't want women to be denied the
opportunity to participate in sports
they don't want to see their kids go to
kindergarten and have this stuff jammed
down their throats and so i just stand
with the people i stand against a lot of
media and a lot of big corporations but
at the end of the day i think we have
the facts and the strength and numbers
on our side yeah i think you're exactly
right thank you it's great to see you
governor desantis of florida
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight